where the next 20 years is really in the
hands of the artists the filmmakers and
storytellers are going to be using the
medium um because really you know what
we're talking about is tools you know i
mean the the they're unbelievable tools
but they're really no different than a
pencil and a piece of paper no one goes
to the you know to milk call
you know or or mark davis or ollie
johnson or frank thompson wow
what pencil did you use
i've got to get me a box of those
you know it really is it's it's it's we
have amazing tools but
but they are they do not create anything
it is really what the filmmakers
you know do with it the foundation of
pixar is is that art challenges
technology and technology inspires the
art i kind of coined that phrase early
on because the way i was working with
bill reese and evan osby and ed capnell
you know i got so inspired by what i was
seeing with the technical development
and then i would come up with ideas i
would have never come up with without
seeing that and then i would challenge
them to do something and then and then i
would see more i get more ideas from
even the mistakes that they would make
oh my gosh you know let's do let's do
something with that you know and and so
it was it was this constant inspiration
that's why i just couldn't
i just got so excited about about the
technology and it kept giving me more
ideas and and and that's really the
foundation of how we work at pixar and
each movie with the development that
we're doing people see it it gets into
your kind of consciousness of what you
can do and then you start challenging it
much further than that